con los meses más fríos a la vuelta de
la esquina lo último que Europa necesita
es una interrupción completa de las
entregas de gas desde Rusia a primera
hora de la mañana del miércoles el
operador europeo de gas en stock anunció
el cese del suministro de gas a su red
el proveedor gas prom dice que es
necesario realizar trabajos de
mantenimiento Y que está previsto que
termine en el sábado pero a diferencia
de la pasada suspensión en julio esta
solo se anunció con dos semanas de
anterioridad el gobierno ruso culpa a
las sanciones occidentales y afirma que
no permitieron un mantenimiento normal o
trabajos de reparación Alemania en donde
termina el gasoducto nordstream 1 ha
acusado en múltiples ocasiones a Moscú
de utilizar la energía como un arma
Putin está jugando con norestream 1 y
nord Stream 2 Creo que es una especie de
juego nuestro problema ahora mismo es
que no estamos en condiciones de
responder adecuadamente a este juego Esa
es la tarea que tenemos por delante
intentar abastecernos lo más posible
el gasoducto nordstrim 1 lleva
funcionando más de una década
transportando miles de millones de
metros cúbicos de gas natural a Europa
pero la guerra en Ucrania y las
consecuentes sanciones han cambiado todo
los países están abasteciendo de gas y
Alemania dice que lleva la delantera en
su objetivo nacional para el 1 de
octubre Mientras tanto Francia tendrá
que reducir aún más su exposición alga
ruso después de que gas prom dijera que
iba a suspender todas las entregas a la
empresa energética engine por no haber
pagado las entregas realizadas en julio